أه
وفقًا للبيانات الجديدة الصادرة للتو
عن مركز مكافحة الأمراض والوقاية ، فإن
البنادق هي
القاتل الأول للأطفال في الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية القاتل الأول أكثر
من حوادث السيارات أكثر من السرطان
[موسيقى]
في سبيل الله كم عدد المذبحة  هل
نحن على استعداد لقبول عدد
أرواح الأمريكيين الأبرياء التي يجب أن تُقتل
قبل أن نقول ما يكفي
[موسيقى]
علينا إعادة حظر الاعتداء على النساء
في المجلات عالية السعة التي
مررناها في عام 1994 بدعم من الحزبين
في الكونغرس وبدعم  من إنفاذ القانون ،
تم تضمين تسع فئات من الأسلحة شبه الآلية في
هذا الحظر مثل AK-47s و ar-15s ، وفي
السنوات العشر الماضية ، انخفض إطلاق النار الجماعي
ولكن بعد أن سمح الجمهوريون
بانتهاء صلاحية القانون في عام 2004
وتم السماح ببيع هذه الأسلحة
مرة أخرى ، تضاعفت عمليات إطلاق النار الجماعية ثلاث مرات ، تلك
هي الحقائق